buonasera a tutti io questa sera
ovviamente di un punto di vista diverso
sulla biodiversità e sul ruolo che
l'agricoltura ha con la biodiversità
abbiamo sentito più volte oggi i vari
interventi parlare dell'agricoltura
quasi come una contrapposizione alla
natura avanza all'agricoltura arretra la
foresta l'agricoltura consuma e 70 per
cento dell'acqua l'agricoltura distrugge
il suolo distrugge le forme viventi
ecco ricordiamoci proprio per la storia
che abbiamo come italiani abbiamo visto
come siamo particolari anche nello
scenario europeo che l'agricoltura
dall'altro lato costruisce paesaggi
costruisce ambienti e quindi plasma fino
nel mini nei minimi pori l'ambiente
all'interno del quale noi viviamo in
fondo in un paese come l'italia
l'agricoltura intesa come la gestione
dei dei sistemi naturali trasformati
dall'uomo per darci cipro fibre legno si
occupa di quasi il 90 per cento del
territorio dove poi noi viviamo è la
storia che vi racconterò questa sera un
piccolo esempio di come l'agricoltura
possa da un lato andare verso una
distruzione di questo meraviglioso mondo
che ha contribuito a costruire ma come
dall'altro parte se ne prende coscienza
possa essere anche uno straordinario
costruttore di ambiente di paesaggio
all'interno del quale poi tutte le
nostre attività si muovono noi siamo
tutti coscienti che negli ultimi anni il
modello di sviluppo che abbiamo tutti
assieme portato avanti ha impresso una
profondissima impronta sulla ambiente
che ci sta intorno
questa stampa di essere meglio secondo
me di qualsiasi altra immagine mi dà
l'idea dell'impronta ecologica così come
ce l'ha voluta a descrivere baker
naguère nel suo famoso algoritmo che
serve oggi alle nazioni per misurare
quanto pesiamo sul nostro ambiente è uno
degli aspetti forse più drammatici
dell'aumento della nostra impronta
ecologica è l'impatto che noi abbiamo
sulla risorsa acqua risorsa che come è
stato mostrato prima per gran parte
viene
utilizzata dall'attività agricola la
quale però spesso è in grado di
riportarla all'ambiente in condizioni
non peggiori di quelle in cui l'ha
trovata ecco noi viviamo in un
particolarissimo territorio siamo
abitanti di questa grande valle presa
tra gli appennini e le alpi la val
padana è una pianura e costruita dai
fiumi una pianura alluvionale
qui vediamo brevemente uno schema che
mostra come questa pianura sia stata
costruita sostanzialmente dal dei fiumi
vedete la vostra sinistra che i fiumi
arrivando in pianura scaricano primi
materiali più pesanti le ghiaie e poi a
mano a mano che si addentrano nella
nostra pianura scaricano i materiali più
fini il imi le argille stratificano
nelle paludi le tombe la pianura alla
fine si organizza come una specie di
torta a strati dove sabbia e lime
argille ghiaie si alternano ma c'è una
finestra che quella dell'alta pianura da
sinistra dell'immagine che state vedendo
dove non esiste questa stratificazione
quindi qualsiasi goccia d'acqua cada in
superficie alla possibilità di
infiltrarsi e poi di correre andando a
ricaricare qualsiasi falda noi troviamo
nel sottosuolo
in queste condizioni
in queste condizioni si disegnano dei
particolarissimi paesaggi e le risorgive
sono dei punti all'interno di questi
paesaggi che sono in parte figlie che
sono in parte figli della di ciò che la
natura fa spontaneamente e in parte
figli dell'azione dell'uomo quei puntini
che vedete nella parte sinistra
dell'immagine con il nome risorgive poi
hanno stomizzato sì uno con l'altro
il punto in cui l'acqua risorge in
pianura come troppo pieno della grande
falda che ci sta sotto
si organizzano dando origine a dei fiumi
i trevigiani conoscono perfettamente il
sile
i vicentini conoscono il bacchiglione
sono fiumi di risorgiva che nascono da
questi punti in cui l'acqua è forzata a
uscire in superficie quando incontra
andando verso valle di strati più
impermeabili
ma questi punti non sono natura sono un
qualcosa che noi in secoli abbiamo
costruito possiamo dire che
nell'ultimo millennio da quando abbiamo
ripreso a mettere ordine nella nostra
pianura
abbiamo cominciato a bonificare a
incanalare l'acqua a inserirla
all'interno di sistemi e ordinati in
modo che il resto della superficie ci
fosse ha dato come disponibile per le
nostre attività
il problema è che con tutto lo
sconvolgimento che il nostro progresso
negli ultimi anni e soprattutto negli
ultimi 30 40 anni ha portato nel nostro
territorio
gran parte delle nostre risorgive stanno
morendo allora prima di capire cosa sta
succedendo cerchiamo un attimo di vedere
come questo fenomeno naturale ha
improntato profondamente l'ambiente che
ci circonda e allora mi faccio correre
rapidamente attraverso delle immagini
che mostrano questi paesaggi delle
risorgive
forse le zone tra le più belle della
nostra pianura
qui siamo nell'alta pianura vicentina
punteggiata di queste piccolissime polle
sono veramente dei punti se voi li
disegnate guardate una mappa per
trovarla dovete andare proprio su un
punto di poche decine o centinaia di
metri quadrati attorno a questi punti si
organizzano dei piccoli corsi d'acqua
spesso con delle acque estremamente
cristalline e attorno a questi corsi
d'acqua attorno a questi capi fonde o
fontanili come vengono chiamati in altre
zone
c'è una straordinaria concentrazione di
biodiversità biodiversità che il trade
union di tutta la nostra chiacchierata
di questo the dix ecco quella
biodiversità la messa lì la natura sono
le piante che sono arrivate da sole sono
gli animali che sono arrivati in assoli
ma noi abbiamo la responsabilità
salvando le risorgive dalla loro morte
della loro distruzione
abbiamo la responsabilità di salvare
anche quella determinata biodiversità
qui vi mostro solo alcuni esempi in
questa bellissima libellula la call of
the licks virgo per esempio stata da
molti in molte zone per esempio aree
naturali protette assurta a simbolo
della risorgiva perché solo dove abbiamo
un'acqua di risorgiva questa livello la
trova alle quali la qualità
dell'ambiente in condizioni tali da
potersi da potersi riprodurre attorno
alle risorgive però non abbiamo solo un
concentrato di biodiversità abbiamo
anche un concentrato di attività
economiche le acque del fiume di
risorgiva sono state sfruttate per far
funzionare ma gli mulini e l'acqua delle
risorgive e fonda
tali in tutta la nostra pianura per
alimentare i nostri sistemi irrigui
purtroppo i fenomeni di sviluppo che
hanno caratterizzato il nostro
territorio stanno rapidamente
compromettendo quei millenari equilibri
tra entrata uscita che hanno generato le
risorgive
tant'è che da qualche decennio sentiamo
anche a livello di media parlare di
morte delle risorgive magari non in
questi giorni che dopo 500 millimetri di
pioggia in poco più di un mese e mezzo
abbiamo anzi il problema della risalita
eccessiva delle acque ma purtroppo
credetemi è un punto anomalo in una
tendenza che ci sta portando invece al
progressivo del parlamento delle nostre
falde così come abbiamo sentito
succedere un po dappertutto nel mondo
dove le esigenze di acqua dei centri
abitati dei sistemi industriali e
dell'agricoltura
continuano a estrarre acqua dalle falde
in modo non sostenibile nel lungo
periodo la morte delle risorgive la
scomparsa di questi straordinari
microambienti che punteggiano il
territorio agricolo e che sono stati
costruiti dall'attività agricola perché
in natura non ci sono le risorgive in
natura ci sono zone acquitrinose dove
l'acqua emerge ma non ci sono dei
sistemi così concentrati e così densi di
biodiversità la morte delle risorgive a
tre cause fondamentali una e il
progressivo in per mille progressiva
impermeabilizzazione del suolo quando
passò da un terreno agricolo a un
terreno parzialmente edificato e arriva
un terreno completamente i denti di
edificato chiaramente non posso più
permettermi di infiltrare abbondanti
quantità di acqua e verso il sottosuolo
dall'altra parte dell'agricoltura
reagisce sostituendo sistemi ad alto uso
di acqua come sistema di all'irrigazione
per scorrimento che vedete in questa
immagine a sistemi più razionali che
risparmiano acqua come i sistemi più
rigori fino ad arrivare all irrigazione
a goccia
però in questo modo è vito che i campi
coltivati impedisco ai campi coltivati e
di perdere acqua che va a ricaricare le
risorgive fino ad arrivare addirittura
alla completa impermeabilizzazione dei
corsi d'acqua a funzione in rigua dove
voglio che ogni goccia d'acqua che io
immettono il corso d'acqua arrivi a
destinazione e guai che io perdo una
goccia d'acqua durante
la fase di trasferimento infine è una
cosa di lungo periodo forse la più
immodificabile assieme
all'urbanizzazione il fatto che abbiamo
preso i nostri fiumi nell'alta pianura
ricchi di ghiaie li abbiamo intensamente
scavati e abbiamo provocato
l'abbassamento degli alberi oggi tutti
gli alberi dei nostri fiumi nella zona
pedemontana si trovano alcuni metri al
di sotto del livello che avevano solo 56
50 60 anni fa e quindi hanno trasformato
i fiumi da disperdenti che quindi
andavano a ricaricare le falde e a fare
quindi alimentare le risorgive in
drenanti quindi svuotato ri delle falde
che stanno loro attorno ecco intorno
alla coscienza che in molte delle nostre
comunità si è venuta sviluppando circa
cosa stavamo perdendo di questo nostro
patrimonio comune sono nate idee sono
nate iniziative
una di queste prende il nome di aree
forestali di infiltrazione consiste
nell'andare a creare all'interno di
appezzamenti agricoli che gli
agricoltori mettono in modo liberale a
disposizione a fronte di una
remunerazione del servizio che svolgono
andare a ricreare artificialmente dei
reticoli dei pettini di canalette che
disperdono l'acqua questi pettini
vengono alimentati durante la stagione
invernale quando i fiumi sono ricchi di
acqua l'acqua non viene richiesta per
l'agricoltura e quindi messi dentro
questi pettini di canalette disperdenti
l'acqua invece che correre nei nostri
fiumi che hanno un tratto molto corso
corto che in pochi giorni portano
l'acqua dalle nostre montagne al mare
l'acqua la trasferiamo in questo immenso
bacino che sta sotto ai nostri piedi che
il sistema pluri falde che sta sotto ai
nostri piedi quindi non andiamo ad
occupare delle superfici con laghi
artificiali a sparare valli eccetera
eccetera ma trasferiamo una parte della
portata dei nostri fiumi che andrebbe
preview volete persa è buttata a mare
molto rapidamente e la mettiamo in banca
sostanzialmente sotto i nostri piedi
e alla fine è curioso notare come
abbiamo preso un qualcosa che non
funzionava bene quasi un problema un
corso d'acqua che mi serviva a prendere
l'acqua dal fiume per irrigare e che
perdeva acqua e quindi che non funziona
va proprio bene
e anzi ho preso quel suo difetto il
fatto di perdere a quello trasformato in
una dote voglio che perde acqua e lo
faccio all'interno di strutture molto
specializzate attorno alla canaletta
pianto degli alberi come faceva il
contadino una volta lungo la roggia
irrigua a lui serviva la legna da ardere
per alimentare la sua cucina economica
per poter avere il legname che gli
serviva per la casa e qui noi piantiamo
gli alberi lungo le canalette invece
perché gli apparati radicali con il
sistema microbico che vive attorno agli
apparati radicali funzionano da
straordinario bio depuratore quindi
sostanzialmente facciamo una depurazione
un affinamento anzi biologico dell'acqua
che stiamo infiltrando in modo da avere
maggiori garanzie per quanto riguarda la
ricarica artificiale della falda
il sistema ha un difetto mi ha detto una
volta qualcuno costa quasi niente e
quindi e poco interessanti per quanto
riguarda certi ambienti dove invece
tutte le cose per essere interessanti
devono avere un certo costo
qui vediamo fra l'altro con con
quest'immagine vedete quanto rapidamente
guardando le date
il sistema può entrare in funzione tre
anni dopo la messa a dimora il sistema è
già perfettamente funzionante infiltra e
nel tempo stesso gli alberi che si sono
sviluppati rapidamente sono in grado di
depurare l'acqua che che stiamo
infiltrando quanto funziona questo
sistema
quanta acqua riusciamo a portare nel
sottosuolo perché ovviamente come tutte
le cose bisogna che il gioco valga
quanto meno la candela allora occupare
una piccola parte del tessuto delle
aziende agricole delle nostre aree di
alta pianura dove abbiamo le ghiaia dove
possiamo più facilmente in filtrare
l'acqua con dei sistemi mirati per la
ricarica della falda vale la pena
ecco abbiamo raccolto fatto molte
esperienze raccolto dei numeri e per
farvela così un tanto al chilo come si
dice non sto a mostrarvi i numeri
precisi delle varie aree sperimentali ma
diciamo che nei terreni migliori
riusciamo infiltrare tra settembre e
maggio quindi fuori della stagione
irrigua dove l'acqua la destiniamo
soprattutto
funzione di irrigazione dei campi si
riescono ad infiltrare circa un milione
di metri cubi di acqua su un ettaro di
superficie un milione di metri cubi
se volete visualizzarlo nell'immagine
che ho le mie spalle è questo cubo è un
ettaro di superficie 100 metri per 100
metri per 100 metri di altezza quindi è
come se voi mettete sopra quel ettaro di
superficie un battente di 100 metri di
acqua che è una quantità veramente
imponente è questa
nel mentre io la porto all'interno dei
campi si infiltra senza andarne occupare
una superficie come invece avrei dovuto
fare
se avessi fatto un invaso artificiale
ecco l'idea è nata qualche anno fa è
stata rapidamente ripresa un'agenzia
delle nazioni unite ha scelto questa
iniziativa semplice e povera che si può
fare ovunque nel mondo qui non c'è hi
tech qui non c'è la frontiera
dell'innovazione tecnologica qui stiamo
prendendo delle cose molto contadine
molto semplici e le stiamo l'inter
pretendo harper dare una risposta ad
un'emergenza dei nostri giorni
in pochi anni nella nell'alta pianura
della nostra della della nostra regione
le aree forestali di filtrazione hanno
cominciato a diffondersi in questo
momento i gruppi di ricerca di varie
università stanno andando a vedere le
altre funzioni che le aree di ricarica
possono svolgere dalla produzione di
biomassa alla depurazione
all'affinamento di altri divari reflui
per esempio i reflui zootecnici mi piace
portare questo come esempio di come
l'agricoltura nella sua opera millenaria
di trasformazione del territorio non
debba sempre essere messa sul tavolo
degli imputati ma ogni tanto possa
essere messa anche sul banco di coloro
che dimostrano concretamente a casa loro
di prendersi cura dell'ambiente che ci
sta attorno
grazie